tu imagines Vincent Lindon il marche
comme ça nombreusement vers juillet de
Binoche il se fait attaquer par des
ninjas de part et d'autre
là il se passe quelque chose
moi je vous fais des
Juliette
oui c'est vrai mais
attendez pas cette intervention
c'est un militant du collectif
écologiste dernière rénovation qui a
interpellé en tout cas qui a tenté de
s'approcher du président le service de
sécurité la repousser et puis c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui est revenu à sa
hauteur et là vous allez le voir s'en
suit un échange assez tendu voire très
tendu entre les deux hommes
qui sont en jeu on ne peut plus demander
gentiment
c'est pas un débat monsieur c'est pas un
débat c'est pour vous annoncer qu'on ne
se laissera pas faire on ne peut plus
laisser faire qu'est-ce que tu fais
qu'est-ce qu'il dit nous sommes avec
Stéphane Manigod restaurateur bonjour
Stéphane salut les GG salut tout le
monde et salut la France qui travaille
l'artisan et ceux qui sont en vacances
pour tous les gens qui cherchent aussi
du travail
mon ami les choix d'Emmanuel Macron en
tout cas semble pas payant puisque avec
32 % de Français satisfaits ça code de
popularité est au plus bas depuis 3 ans
oui coup dur pour le président qui reste
quand même derrière le numéro 1 de la
popularité Pierre Palmade mais passe
devant le jovial
alors écrit des sketchs très drôle
d'ailleurs
il est un peu moins marrant je rajoute
des ninjas Juliette sur la vie de ma
mère on fait un malheur
je l'ai vu le film bien sûr
j'étais un peu surpris voir même un peu
choqué d'entendre le président de la
comédie c'est une chaîne qui se
rapproche de Fox News de la chaîne
d'opinion non c'est une chaîne française
100% française et qui exprime toutes les
opinions en même temps Fox News Fox News
de ce que j'ai une tête de Fox News
[Rires]
[Musique]
fallait que ça tombe sur moi sur la tête
de ma mère fallait que ça tombe sur moi
c'est un délire
c'est un délire c'est pas
prévu
mon grand-père en avait c'est un peu
rétré
c'est un accessoire un accessoire
alors c'est la période des lumières on
est d'accord là alors après ça va des
lumières alors là
[Applaudissements]
pour noter les spectateurs qui n'ont
jamais vu une éclipse regardez hop
en tout cas là où on se parle ce qu'on
voulait dire oui ce qu'on voulait dire
qu'on voulait dire qui était important
c'est que le cinéma pas la famille du
cinéma c'est même pas passé
ce t-shirt tu peux arrêter de cérémonie
pardon on y retourne en 4 alors ça c'est
un petit point d'histoire c'est Joseph
gayeti qui est l'inventeur du papier
toilette simple épaisseur
on n'est pas contre le papier toilette
simple épaisseur jusqu'au jour ou un
petit peu pressé on se met
involontairement un doigt dans l'anus ça
nous est tous arrivé et c'est un petit
moment suspendu c'est un moment c'est un
moment sucré salé c'est un moment
aigre-doux j'ai fait une boulette une
toute petite boulette et une dame toute
mignonne dans la file pour entrer là
vous savez on est là on sait pas quoi
faire dans son manteau dans les mains en
piétine et puis moi gentil je lui dis
c'est votre première fois au César elle
me dit oui je dis vous êtes de la
famille d'un dénommé cela va faire
quelque chose
quelqu'un de sa famille qui peut-être
dans quelques instants s'apprête à
recevoir un César là elle me coupe elle
me dit non Jérôme je suis la ministre de
la Culture
mais qu'est-ce que tu as fait à tes
cheveux Roselyne tu as tout lycée une
vache de concours c'est comme une star
ça se bichonne
du grand art pour certains
la crêpe de cette vache est blanchie au
talc
[Musique]
et fixé à la laque
elle me dit non je suis celle d'après je
suis après moi j'ai en même temps sans
vous faire offense même la ministre vous
avez une notoriété en devenir voilà non
mais
vous êtes pas emmerdé quand vous faites
vos courses quoi
on n'est pas prêts à la mi-temps du
Super Bowl c'est
mais c'est une information très sérieuse
Rihanna sera la star du salon de
l'agriculture qui s'ouvre demain à Paris
la fameuse Rihanna qui n'a rien à voir
avec la chanteuse je ne connais pas du
tout la chanteuse j'essaie de trouver
des noms un peu originaux Rihanna ça va
être la star des vols
ne sont qu'en présentation là il y a pas
de concours mais c'est une très belle
vache reste maintenant à l'égard des
propres toute la nuit
ça va se passer comme ça
[Musique]
ça va se passer derrière les vaches
éviter qu'elle se salisse
[Musique]
ils étaient allés ils étaient allés
ramasser à trois potes donc leur
camarades à peu près toutes les portes
de chiens possibles de Paris qu'ils
avaient mis dans des sauts en plastique
énorme et ils allaient sur le pont qui
était je crois le pont Bir laquelle je
suis pas sûr que je suis Albert
exactement
[Rires]
c'est vrai je rêve ou il pisse dans mon
eau et ensuite il la boit
j'aime pas les babouins
et boivent mon eau
c'est pas sympa
et le point cuisson de 20 heures c'est
le dernier de la semaine pour Thomas
beno voilà d'autres chefs du restaurant
ardent vous allez être regretté cher
Thomas